Ukraine is the Paris Hilton of countries…
anytime it’s in the news, it’s not for
anything good.
For the last few decades, Ukraine has been
the
scene of the worst nuclear catastrophe, a
military conflict with Russia and the biggest
corruption scandals you can imagine.
But… look, there is another thing Ukrainian
politicians have in common with Paris Hilton:
they both have a lot of money.
After the fall of the
Soviet Union, Ukraine’s economy stopped
being managed by the state and started being
managed by the state’s friends.
These are the so called
oligarchs and you can find them in all of
the country’s political parties, pro Russian
and anti Russian alike.
For example, the current
president, PETRO POROSHENKO is also known
as the ‘King of Chocolate’ because he
owns the biggest chocolate company in the
country.
And the
former president, YULIA TIMISHENKO is known
as the ‘Gas Princess’ because she made
a lot of money in the gas industry.
In other words: things
changed, but everything stayed the same.
Nonetheless, things are really starting to
change in Ukraine.
But, make no mistake; these changes are not
for the better.
In fact, the opposite
is true.
You see, in a previous video, we told you
how Russia is Europe’s main gas provider.
For example, Germany buys 60% of their natural
gas from
Russian companies like GAZPROM or ROSNEFT.
And how does this gas arrive?
Well…
most of it comes from gas pipes that cross
Ukrainian soil.
So what does this all mean?
It means that, despite Ukraine having little
gas resources, they are still a hot spot in
this business.
And this… is
when Vladimir Putin comes into the picture!
To this day, Putin needs Ukraine to supply
Europe with gas.
But, as you know, the relationship between
Putin and Kiev currently has a status of
‘it’s complicated’, to say the least.
So after decades of love and Slavic fraternity,
the Government of Ukrainian president Poroshenko
wants to
stay away from Putin as much as possible.
As you can imagine, this political divorce
doesn’t make Russia happy.
Anytime their gas goes through Ukrainian territory,
they have to pay a
millionaire’s share of alimony to their
ex wife.
But this is not the end of the story!
As long as Ukraine is in the center of the
gas routes,
Kiev will have a better position to negotiate
with Moscow and even Brussels.
In other words: Ukraine matters as long as
we need them for gas.
So what’s Putin’s strategy, then?
Well, check this out.
Russians Insist On New Pipeline To Bypass
Ukraine, And Europeans Fine With It
Yes, my dear viewers, Russia wants to take
Ukraine out of the gas route equation.
This way, Ukraine would lose their strategic
value, which
would mean that neither America, nor the European
Union would really care about them in the
case of a potential new Russian invasion.
So the question now is…
Can this strategy work?
Will the European Union let Russia bypass
Ukraine?
Today we’re going to answer all of these
questions but, before we do, let’s take
a look back at the history.
IF YOU ARE NOT MINE, THEN YOU WILL NOT BE
ANYBODY ELSE’S
In the year 2000, 70% of the Russian gas arriving
to Europe came from Ukraine.
More specifically, it came from the so called
BROTHERHOOD gas
pipe.
This pipeline was built in the times of the
Soviet Union and it become more important
as the demand for Russian gas grew.
The other 30%
came from the YAMAL pipe, in Belarus, but
that’s another story.
When the Soviet Union fell apart, Ukraine
became an independent nation.
And this was the moment when the Kiev politicians
started to see the
business clearly.
“Russia has the gas reserves but they need
us to sell to the Germans so… they should
pay us a fare.”
Nowadays, this fare is more than 2 billion
dollars a year, but it used to be even higher.
Thanks to the so called TRANSIT RIGHTS, the
State
owned gas company in Ukraine, NAFTOGAZ, became
a behemoth: all of this, despite having almost
no gas resources in the country.
As you can imagine, this isn’t just about
economics here.
Both in Russia and Ukraine, everything is
a political weapon.
So anytime Kiev had a
Russian friendly government, GAZPROM sold
them cheap gas.
But when Kiev didn’t have Russian friendly
politicians in office, prices went sky
high.
We already discussed this in another video,
the first one in this series on Russian Gas.
The gas negotiations between Russia and Ukraine
led to
a supply cut in 2006 and 2009.
The last one, in 2009, caused the rest of
Europe to go without gas too.
And this was when Russia started a new strategy.
Putin phoned his friend, the former German
chancellor and current ROSNEFT president,
GERHARD
SCHROEDER.
And GERHARD SCHROEDER phoned the current German
chancellor, ANGELA MERKEL.
This is how they sold the first project to
bypass Ukraine:
the NORD STREAM 1 pipeline.
This pipeline goes through the Baltic sea,
straight from Russia to Germany.
One year later, in 2010, YANUKOVICH won the
Ukrainian presidency.
YANUKOVICH is a Pro Russian politician.
So the good times and the cheap gas
prices came back.
But in 2014, we had the EUROMAIDAN.
Do you remember those protests in Kiev?
This took YANUKOVICH out of office and brought
a
brand new anti Russian government to Ukraine.
And this is when Putin said
“If I can’t have you, nobody can.”
Since 2015, GAZPROM, Russia’s main gas company,
started the ultimate plan to bypass Ukraine.
For one, they started the NORDSTREAM 2, through
the
Baltic.
And on the Southern side, Gazprom is building
the TURKSTREAM, that sends gas through the
BLACK SEA as far as Turkey.
According to the
GAZPROM president, by the year 2020, that
good old Brotherhood pipeline will carry less
than 10% of what it used to.
But hold on just a second!
Because, so far, it seems like Russia is just
plain bad and Ukraine is a poor victim, right?
In fact, things are far
more complicated.
Let’s dig deeper into this, shall we?
THE UKRAINIAN JUGGERNAUT
Naftogaz is far more than a gas company.
In fact, it’s sort of a job agency!
They have more than 175,000 workers.
Yes, you heard that right.
To
put that into perspective, the equivalent
of Naftogaz in Poland, PGNIG, which is also
owned by the state, only employs 25,000 people.
In other words, in Ukraine, you’re nobody
if you don’t have a relative working for
Naftogaz.
As you can imagine, Naftogaz is a black hole
on Ukrainians’ finances.
It’s like if Paris Hilton was taking care
of the accounting.
You know,
with so many people working for a state owned
enterprise, money disappears and nobody knows
why.
According to the Institute for Economic
Research and Policy Consulting, a Ukrainian
think tank, NAFTOGAZ loses more than 3 billion
dollars a year from corruption.
This company is
always reporting financial loses.
And we aren’t talking about a little bit
of money here.
Just in 2014, Naftogaz losses accounted for
6% of the
entire Ukrainian GDP.
But right there, in 2014, we had the Euromaidan.
And that meant very fast changes.
Changes like this one.
Ukrainian police detain Naftogaz Chairman
of Board Yevhen Bakulin
The new CEO of the company is this man you
see on the screen, ANDRIY KOBOLIEV, a 40 year
old consultant.
His job could be summarized in two
goals: ending corruption and ending Russian
dependency.
And now you might wonder… is he serious
about this?
Well… so far, things look good.
Both the European Union and IMF have pushed
Ukraine to do
their homework and, it seems like they are
trying…
GSE announces new improvements of the storage
transparency initiative - Naftogaz of Ukraine
joins Gas Storage Inventory (AGSI+)
Since then, Naftogaz has started to make a
profit.
After decades of financial losses, now they
account for 13% to the Ukrainian state’s
income.
And now you might wonder… what did KOBOLYEV
do?
What was his magic formula?
First of all, as is always the case with state
monopolies, the prices were controlled by
the Government.
This meant really cheap gas, and
Ukrainian consumers who were used to paying
these artificially low prices.
Now, Naftogaz has raised prices to a level
equal to that of other
European countries.
Second of all, Kobolyev has confronted Putin
with a lot of… lateral thinking.
You see, Gazprom wanted to raise gas prices
for Ukraine.
But not
for the rest of the European countries.
So what did Ukraine do?
Instead of fighting with Moskow, they started
to buy gas from other European
countries like…
Slovakia.
But, wait, wait a minute here…
Does Slovakia have gas resources?
Of course not!
Listen to this.
The contracts with GAZPROM say that, once
the gas arrives in an EU country, Russia loses
control over it.
This means that, the buyer can do
whatever they want with the gas.
So now, Slovakia gets their Russian gas through
the Brotherhood pipe and, then, it goes through
the same pipe,
back to Ukraine.
So Slovakia buys Russian gas and then Ukraine
buys it from Slovakia.
Thanks to this, Naftogaz has cut a fourth
of their
importing costs.
But this is just the beginning!
Kobolyev keeps looking for alternatives!
For example?
AZERBAIJAN.
As we said in other videos, Azerbaijan has
lots of gas.
And they are building a pipeline, the TRANS
ANATOLIAN, which goes to Italy.
Kiev wants to connect to this pipe through
Bulgaria.
But… we’ll dig deeper into this in our
closing video for this series.
Because, believe me, Azerbaijan is another
interesting topic that deserves
a video on its own.
If you don’t want to miss it, don’t forget
to subscribe.
So going back to our story, it seems that
Ukraine is doing a great job cleaning up corruption,
right?
Well… wait a minute because, as we always
say on VisualPolitik, not everything is all
sunshine and rainbows.
If Ukraine wants to fully adapt to European
standards, they should liberalize
their gas market.
This would mean that Naftogaz would no longer
be a monopoly and they would have to split
the company into several, smaller
ones.
One would be focused on gas production, another
one would manage domestic consumption… and
so on.
And, as you can imagine, this is where
the problems come in!
EU and Ukraine in tug of war over Naftogaz
unbundling
As you can imagine, as much as Kobolyev wants
to clean up the company, too many oligarchs
have been too good to the company for too
long.
Yes,
the company can be owned by the state but…
this is no excuse to not have millionaire
salaries and millionaire bribes.
And this is hard to just
stop from one day to the next.
But this is not the worst part!
You see… in march 2019, Ukraine will have
elections again.
And the result will be decisive for Naftogaz’s
future.
And… of course, my dear viewers, Russia
has a perfectly defined agenda for this.
Let’s have a look at it!
ECONOMICS VERSUS GEOPOLITICS
Germany has made it all clear: they will build
the NORDSTREAM 2 pipeline.
Both Brussels and Washington are against it.
In fact, Donald Trump has
been the biggest critic.
He kind of said that even Paris Hilton would
do a better job than Germany when it comes
to having a good energy policy.
And now you might wonder…
How is it possible that Angela Merkel has
let herself be seduced by Vladimir Putin?
Yes, you know that the former
German chancellor, Gerhard Schroeder, is Putin’s
man in Europe.
But… there is more to it than that.
Basically, Germany has a big dilemma.
On one hand, their industry needs gas.
A LOT of gas.
The safer and cheaper, the better.
And, putting
politics aside, NordStream 2 is the best option
economy wise.
First, it is cheap.
Second, it avoids all the potential gas wars
with Ukraine.
The problem?
This gaspipe would make Germany even more
dependent on Russia.
Meanwhile, Putin is happy.
He can bypass Ukraine and also, destroy their
economy.
In this regard, Russia’s intentions are
more obvious than your
ex girlfriend’s when she wanted to “have
a coffee with you”.
Want an example?
Have a look at this map!
This is the Black sea.
And this little sea to the North is the AZOV
sea.
Both seas are connected by the KERCH strait.
And Ukraine has two
important harbours in the AZOV sea.
So what did Russia do?
They built a bridge right at the Kerch strait.
A bridge that makes most of the ships
unable to arrive or to leave the Azov sea.
This is why you hear so much news about military
escalation in this region now.
So now you might wonder… why is Russia trying
so hard to bankrupt Ukraine?
It is all about jealousy?
Of course not!
The thing is… the worse the
anti Russian Ukrainian government does, the
better things are for the pro Russian candidates
in the elections.
And is there any pro Russian candidate running
in the 2019 Ukrainian elections?
Well… the answer is… anything is possible
here!
Here’s an example of how crazy this country
can be.
In Ukraine they have a TV show called ‘Servant
of the people’.
The star is a teacher who
fights corruption.
OK, so there’s already an actual political
party based on this series.
The actor who plays the role of that teacher
is the
candidate.
His name is VLADIMIR ZELENSKY.
And… does he have any real chance of winning?
Well… just look at this.
Tymoshenko leading presidential candidate
poll, followed by Poroshenko, Zelensky and
Hrytsenko
Yes, you heard that right.
He’s in the third place, followed by the
King of Chocolate and the Gas Princess.
So… yes, it is impossible to predict
what’s going to happen.
There is just one clear thing in this story.
And that’s that AZERBAIJAN is having a really
good time.
But we’ll talk
about this in the next video.
So in the meantime, the question for you is…
What would you do if you were Germany?
Would you take that cheap
Russian gas in exchange for leaving Ukraine
alone?
Or you would sacrifice competitiveness for
political interest?
Please, leave your answer in
the comments section below.
Also, visit RECONSIDER MEDIA.COM, the podcast
that provided the vocals in this episode that
were not mine.
If you liked this video, give us a
thumbs up and, as always, I’ll see you next
time.